when you're a kid imagination is
limitless and inspiration can come from
anywhere
so when seven-year-old jeremy rowan had
to choose a costume for
dress as your idol day at school he knew
exactly who he wanted to be
this is jeremy and this is who he chose
to dress up as
poet amanda gorman who he says recites
poetry
like it's a song she is america's first
youth poet laureate
like millions of people jeremy was
mesmerized by her grace her dignity and
her words
at the inauguration of u.s president joe
biden
when day comes we step out of the shade
a flame and unafraid the new dawn blooms
as we free it for there was always light
if only were brave enough to see it if
only
were brave enough to be it
she stepped into that moment of history
and took people's breath away
there is a renaissance in poetry right
now and it's not just driven by gorman
there are plenty of emerging eloquent
poets including here in canada
whose voices are rising robin gill has
the story
of some of them i was in ocean once
bare shoulders and whale song in my rib
cage i watched
as the rigs drilled holes in my body
they left no part of my trenches
unmanned
poetry has always been a form of art but
rarely a career
turned me into a war instead of a
homecoming
i should have evaporated sooner and yet
nisha patel has managed to make this
a full-time gig it's definitely not the
sexiest job to dream of when you're you
know 10 years old
other jobs seem more important seem
bigger seem
you know wider in their scope seem like
they're going to reach more people
but to dream of being an artist in the
literary sense is very different
this place is a love song a changing
season's memoir
a passage of time captured in the
buildings
and the businessman's dreams the 28 year
old's dream came true when edmonton
picked her as the city's poet laureate
there's a level of recognition
that comes into being a poet laureate
and so a lot of your words
are not taken you know lightly you're
able to occupy a space that
the public is able to see like a lot of
young poets
she taught herself by reading it that's
how toronto's
andrea josek got her start uber driver
jaw opens
a boa constrictor after fast there are
other women in his molars
this is a second dusk i was always very
interested in writing ever since i was a
kid
and for the longest time i thought that
writing had to be limited to a page and
to publications and
to books as a shy teenager she started
entering slam poetry competitions
and the words inside her started flowing
out
what i like about poetry is how
healing it can be it feels like a place
of complete liberated self-expression
it feels like a place where however
you're feeling that day or however
you're feeling in that moment can be
fully released i stand on stolen land
watch as flash flood and acid rain
embraces home
on the news a pig swims in the world
sees resilience
born in the philippines now living in
vancouver ivyadad was taking journalism
courses and decided to delve into
creative writing
event water towards mahala
the cost of a body is an empty home i
had to take a poetry class even though i
hated poetry at the time
um and then i dipped my teeth okay let's
rewind yeah
you actually hated poetry when you first
started creative writing and now you're
a poet
i never knew that i could have um
that i could have the mental capacity
for it the immediacy
of it is part of its charm part of
poetry's charm and power
kevin connolly is the poetry editor at
the house of a nancy
a publishing company he says poetry
plays an important role in times of
turbulence and unease
like during a pandemic i think in times
like this
people are at a loss for words i mean i
often ask people how they're doing
[Music]
people are having really awful time and
many people
whose life isn't all that changed and a
lot of them are at a loss for words they
can't quite
distill it and i think a poem can do
that because it's so specific to a
moment
uh a particular person's experience even
something that happened that day
he sees a surge of young poets
especially ones from marginalized
communities
these poets recognize the moment they're
in
some days i cannot see past the blood on
my hands
i read names like a eulogy the leopards
the gorillas the elephants the sea
turtles
the rhinos the tigers oh god how i had
never wished to outlive the tigers
when i first got into poetry it was i
was dealing with
a lot of mental health struggles and a
lot of my poetry focused on mental
health and focused on
you know moving through mental illness
and existing with mental illness
josek frequently writes about sexual
assault gender
issues and her personal struggles and
then
as i started to unpack more of my
healing i moved towards dealing with
survivorship and dealing with being you
know
a femme body in a society that is very
male focused in a society that
discourages
femininity and discourages the woman
for what are the boxes i encounter men
in but the packaging of their temptation
i am prayed into wrapping paper and
reused at every convenience
people write poetry out of a position of
anxiety they're much more comfortable
with anxiety than regular people
that's their strength and their weakness
but at times like this it seems like a
strength
edmonton was one of the first cities in
canada to formally establish a poet
laureate
in that role patel is the people's poet
your job as a poet laureate is to
reflect the times
and the thoughts and the feelings of the
people and a lot of my work as poet
laureate
has been in some ways more controversial
because it's critical
of the institutions around me she sure
isn't cow towing to the hand that feeds
her
here's her recent blistering attack on
city hall so i lay awake and wonder
which part of the municipal government
act
section 7 prevents the city from
spending money in a crisis
in the name of the safety health and
welfare of people
the fact patel is able to make a living
from her lyrics
has inspired this rising poet vancouver
is a demolished rainforest surrounded by
sacred mountains flattened for
skyscrapers surrey
is the pavement where mama tells me to
dream
poetry distills ideas down to a few
words
spread apart on a lot of white space no
wonder instagram has been a vehicle for
young poets
but critics of insta poetry describe it
as a few
superficial lines thrown together and
put into a square box
the spectator writes the vast majority
of instant poetry
is terrible cliched banal derivative
portentous repetitive and manipulative
i think you know young poets are not
always eloquent some of them
have difficult feelings complicated
feelings messy feelings right and to
capture that spirit in poetry even as
they grow older
i think is more human than some of these
old poets that are published in books
that we study for like hundreds of years
patel herself uses
instagram a platform she says helps
spread the word
but that also comes with its challenges
at the end of the day
i'm being put into this position where i
have to look at engagement numbers i
have to look at
whether a poem is landing in a in a good
way whether people are identifying with
it
and that part just it's like a worm that
gets into my brain and i'm really trying
to
reach a point with my writing where i'm
at peace where i can
offer what i want into the universe and
i don't have to accept
that social media metrics or how the
universe is telling me that what i'm
doing is right
connecting does depend on getting those
likes
chaucer and elliot had to worry about
followers and metrics
but it was a different era their works
have generally been relegated to the
musty corners of bookstores and
libraries but they're still taught by
the old establishment
do you think that poetry is still in
that realm of being traditional or
elitist or exclusive anymore
we're still preferencing people who go
to school for writing we're still
preferencing people
who sometimes have to write for 10 plus
years in order for them to be heard
they called me a coke nun brown on the
outside white
on the inside inside there is only 24
years
of hollowing yourself out patel didn't
pursue
publishing but a book deal has landed in
her lap
coconut is her debut to be filled by
someone else's expectations
so that you like a real coconut
can be judged in the palms of others and
i hope to
continue to build momentum i feel
momentous i feel like i'm caught up in
something
um that is bigger than me and i want to
see that through till the end whatever
the ending might be